en 1950 simone de beauvoir reçoit la
lettre suivante je rédige ces lignes en
cachette de mon mari j'ai peur qu'il me
surprennent je suis très malheureuse
avec lui il est violent mais votre livre
me donne le courage d'imaginer une autre
vie
[Musique]
des lettres comme celle ci simone de
beauvoir en reçoit des centaines depuis
la sortie du deuxième sexe des femmes
qui veulent avorter alors que la loi
l'interdît des homosexuels qui se
cachent des femmes au foyer coincés dans
leur mariage
la femme reste toujours subordonné à
l'homme la plupart du temps elle est
vraiment un objet sexuel ou une servante
économique est toujours sous payé là
plutôt des chances égales à celles de
l'homme
elle est toujours assez harry à la
maternité au foyer je ne crois pas du
tout que le progrès le deuxième sexe
s'est imposé comme la référence des
féministes du monde entier et la vie que
vos voix recette inventée sert de modèle
on est condamné à être libre et donc on
est condamné à se battre on ne peut pas
s'enfermer simplement dans le statut de
victime
il ya l'intelligence est derrière et à
la volonté quoi y'a vraiment la volonté
en marche
elle sait ce qu'elle veut elle va y
aller beauvoir est née au début du 20e
siècle
à l'époque on ne reconnaît ni le droit
de vote des femmes ni l'autonomie
financière ni l'avortement est lourd
jeudi la cage de la prison dans
lesquelles sont enfermés les femmes
depuis des millénaires ou rendez compte
c'était enthousiasmant
elle est devenue une icône de la révolte
elle a compris mieux que personne que
rien n'est jamais acquis
aux etats unis face aux conservateurs
qui remettent en cause l'avortement on
la cite n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira
d'une crise politique économique aux
religieuses pour que les droits des
femmes soient remises en question
l'auteur des mémoires d'une jeune fille
rangée est une figure centrale en
occident mais pas seulement dans le
monde dans lequel j'ai grandi au maroc
mais avec le tennis que je côtoie dans
le monde arabe en arabie saoudite en
egypte
elles ont tout lu beauvoir et beauvoir à
tous pour toutes ces filles a représenté
à basculement dans leur ville
[Musique]
mais beauvoir et trop souvent réduite à
l'image d'une militante austère alors
qu'elle était infiniment plus humaine et
maintenant voici une nouvelle qui
intéressera toutes les maîtresses de
maison un stop gaz automatique du four
permettra aux maîtresses de maison de
rejoindre leurs maris à la pêche
son regard sur la réalité de la vie des
femmes est formidablement concret elle
parle de la charge mentale de la double
journée des hommes qui ne font rien ou
si peu à la maison et si les femmes chez
lipp la révolution sur ce plan là sur le
plan du travail ménager s'est lui refusé
c'est obliger les amateurs avec qu'elle
a très bien si ce qui est échangé toute
la société en seraient bouleversés
l analyse le machisme ordinaire
la femme objet réduite à un trophée à un
appareil reproducteur
dans les plus dix bonnes années 50 elle
n'hésite pas à parler des règles du
titre rice elle assume sa liberté
sexuelle
mais comment a t'elle conquis sa liberté
car elle n'est pas née beauvoir elle
l'est devenue
[Musique]
tout commence dans le paris chic de la
belle époque
[Musique]
c'est dans ce monde que si bonne voie le
jour dans un bel immeuble du boulevard
montparnasse le 9 janvier 1908
[Musique]
sa mère françoise viens d'une famille
riche et pieuse son père est un avocat
monde un beau parleur
comme dans la plupart des familles
bourgeoises
les veaux voir vivent essentiellement de
leur rente les mariages sont arrangés
preto la petite simone montre un
caractère exceptionnel
elle a les yeux d'une petite fille qui
pense et en même temps une énergie sur
le visage et même dans sa position qui
ne fait que attirer le regard
toute jeune elle a une conscience aiguë
d'être avant tout un être autonome à 7
ans alors qu'elle joue au jardin du
luxembourg
une dame la félicite pour ses ravissants
petits mollets simone s'indigne je ne
suis pas un corps
je suis moi enfant elle dévore tous les
livres c'est elle qui apprend à lire à
sa soeur cadette et très vite elle
commence à écrire elle rédige un livre
de 100 pages qui commence par ses lignes
marguerite elle prend soin de ses soeurs
du ménage
mais j'ai commencé à vouloir vraiment
écrire je sais que cela s'était très
décidés berquez sur un carnet comment
non les jeunes filles et vous me
demandez quelles étaient mes préférences
le travail qui ya quelques kilomètres
plus tard et j'avais écrit la fin de vie
du tour un écrivain célèbre moi je serai
une auteur célèbre elle le sait elle a
même presque le sentiment qu'on
l'appelle elle dit qu'elle entend une
sorte de voie en elle quelque chose qui
dit qu' elle sera quelqu'un quand je
marchais pour une femme
c'était la meilleure et même peut-être à
la seule façon que je voyais à l'époque
à moi d'être reine d'angleterre de se
faire à nous d'être quelqu'un
[Musique]
dès l'âge de 9 ans simone est inscrite
aux cours désirent un institut
catholique pour jeunes filles de bonne
famille à l'époque
simone est très croyante et elle
conservera sa vision binaire du bien et
du mal
même après avoir perdu la foi à 15 ans
[Musique]
dès son arrivée dans cette école elle a
un coup de foudre amical presque
amoureux pour une camarade de classe
elisabeth lac - dit zaza
durant dix ans simone et zaza seront
comme deux soeurs jumelles
[Musique]
zsa zsa vient elle aussi d'une famille
bourgeoise elle impressionne beauvoir
par son intelligence et son insolence
ce hasard rose se moquer de sa mère des
conventions sociales
[Musique]
pour moi c'est asa qui émancipe c'est le
contrepoint c'est celle qui lui dit que
effectivement on peut rêver d'autre
chose que cette vie bourgeoise
les deux inséparables selon leur
expression partagent leurs lectures
satiné en particulier par les auteurs
qui écrivent sur le temps bergson proust
elles sont hantés par le temps qui passe
le temps perdu
le néant
[Musique]
comme simone zaza rêve d'un mariage
romantique elle est amoureuse un jeune
philosophe mais ses rêves vont se briser
ses parents refusent d'envisager son
mariage avec un étudiant sans le sou
folle de chagrin elle déprime tombe
malade
zsa zsa meurent à 21 ans beauvoir ne
l'oubliera jamais elle considère que la
bourgeoisie a tué sa meilleure amie
d'enfance et elles vont en garder une
colère terrible accepté d'être elle-même
ça veut dire dire merde à la bourgeoisie
ça veut dire refuser tous ces codes
refusé cette vie qu'on essaye de lui
imposer
ça va être une une tragédie personnelle
et ça va être le moteur aussi de son
combat faire qu'il n'y ait plus de zaza
faire que plus aucune femme n'est le
besoin de renoncer à ce qu'elle est
parce que les maris parce que le mariage
parce que la religion veut les obliger à
correspondre à certains modèles de
femmes à un éternel féminin dans ses
mémoires d'une jeune fille rangée
beauvoir racontera plus tard comment
elle s'est arraché à la vie bourgeoise
qui l'attendait comment elle a décidé de
ne jamais se sacrifier comme hazard
de ne jamais étouffé ses rêves comme sa
mère
cette femme trompée par son mari qui
s'est usé à tenir son intérieur sa fille
s'est construite en opposition vis-à-vis
de sa mère elle n'a pas envie de tenir
de devenir comme ça et elle comprend
aussi que cette idée du sacrifice cet
été du dévouement malheureusement elles
n'apportent pas épanouissement à la
femme la plupart du temps elle apporte
plutôt du ressentiment de l'aigreur et
je pense qu'elle se dit moi je ne veux
jamais vivre ça elle écrit je me
construire est une force où je me
réfugie rey a jamais je veux vivre la
grande aventure d'être soi
[Musique]
pour voir le sait son salut viendra du
savoir des livres en 1925 après son bac
elle s'inscrit à la sorbonne
pendant quatre ans elle passe ses
journées et ses soirées enfermé à la
bibliothèque sainte geneviève
elle ne s'est pas inscrite à une ou deux
licences mais à huit lettres
mathématiques latin grec sociologie
philosophie
[Musique]
elle fonctionne de façon systématique
elle veut tout savoir et sa puissance de
travail est unique
[Musique]
alors aucun complexe non mais elle
jusqu'à là une telle excitation
intellectuelle de plaisir de penser de
réfléchir de décortiquer les choses que
l y va elle est dans le jeu dans le vrac
le plaisir presque la jouissance
sexuelle intellectuel passionné par la
philo elle veut préparer l'agrégation
mais ses parents s'y opposent ils
veulent bien comprendre qu'elles
puissent faire des lettres et comme ça
ne pourra enseigner elle pourra devenir
institutrice mme de la philo il trouve
là encore aux espèces de pêcher péché
d'orgueil donc elle fait la grève du
silence et face à ses parents qui
refusaient elle refuse de parler ses
parents finissent par céder à partir de
beaurevoir prépare l'agrégation de
philosophie à la sorbonne mais elles ne
bénéficient pas de l'exceptionnel
formation des classes préparatoires
car l'école normale supérieure est alors
interdite aux femmes
et pourtant ses capacités
intellectuelles impressionne les jeunes
normalien croisé au quartier latin
il la surnomme affectueusement le castor
beaver en anglais car distille les
castors vivent en bande et ils ont
l'esprit constructeur un surnom qu'elle
gardera toute sa vie elle fait des
études très rapide elle elle finit sa
licence en même temps qu'elle commence
qu'elle va commencer l'agrégation auquel
brûle les étapes
elle est plus rapide que n'importe qui à
ce moment là en juillet 1929 beauvoir
révise l'agrégation avec la bande de
jeune normalien dont un certain jean
paul sartre
[Musique]
sartre a la réputation d'être le plus
laid le plus sale le plus brillant
le plus drôle très vite il ya une
sympathie très grand emprunt c'est après
mois et puis il était terriblement
obstiné car j'étais arrivé à penser
penser vraiment toute la journée il
était plus intelligent que les autres
tue pas et puis il avait une vitalité
une générosité une chaleur une drôlerie
il fera quelque chose quasi quelqu'un à
mes yeux du mois les traits fascina
sartre et beauvoir sorte premier et
second à l'agrégation une fusion
intellectuelle s'opère ils ne se
quittent plus
[Musique]
sartre répondait exactement aux voeux de
mes 15 ans il était le double anti je me
retrouvais
[Musique]
dialogue s'instaure qui va durer toute
leur vie une alchimie intellectuelle
parce que c'était tel parce que c'était
lui
un amour qui les renforcent sans les
asservir
ce sont deux consciences libres qui se
rencontrent et qui ont envie de cheminer
ensemble dans dans la vie sans
s'empêcher sans empêcher l'autre de
faire ce qu'il a envie de faire je les
vois pour ma part - comme des amants
magnifiques que comme une une relation
[Musique]
jeu très fluide entre les deux très
tendre
il ya quelque chose pour moi de
fraternelles entre les deux et qui ne
pourra jamais se casser au vent
en 1931 pour son premier poste
elle est nommé professeur à marseille
quant à sartre l'éducation nationale
l'envoi au havre
[Musique]
la séparation est cruel mais quand
sartre lui propose le mariage seule
façon d'être muté dans la même ville
elle refuse sans hésiter pas question de
céder au modèle bourgeois
[Musique]
bon voir qu'on saigne la philosophie au
lycée de filles mon grand elle choque
ses collègues en faisant l'éloge
d'auteur homosexuels comme andré gide
[Musique]
dès qu'elle a du temps libre elle écrit
commence un roman inspiré du drame deux
hazard et les week-ends
elle se lance dans des escapades autour
de marseille elle peut marcher jusqu'à
10 heures
chaussés de simples espadrilles elle
veut tout découvrir et n'hésite pas à
partir seul sur les chemins
je me disais bon bah de toute façon je
vivrai sans peur je peux avoir peur
l'associer à la part de ceux là c'est
toujours était plutôt affronter les
dangers que les fuir
là aussi elle est une espèce d'énergie
parce qu'elle fait un moment elle se
lance on des randonnées mais
complètement daguin de marche pendant
des heures tout seul a les pieds en sang
et à l'avancé à la vancelle avance
beaurevoir sort plus forte de cette
année marseillaise
elle a su maîtriser sa peur de la
solitude en 1932 elle est nommée à rouen
pas loin du à vous enseigne sartre
depuis leur rencontre ils forment un
couple libre avant l'heure
dans le pacte qu'ils ont scellé ils sont
là pour l'autre l'amour nécessaire mais
s'autorise selon leur formule des amours
contingentes parallèle entre rouen le
havre et paris
se met en place autour d'eux ce qu'ils
nomment la petite famille
il s'appelle bost olga wanda
la plupart ont été leurs élèves ils
habitent dans de modestes hôtel écrivent
font la fête picole tombe amoureux bon
voire couche avec bost mais aussi avec
olga lydia effectivement une
fréquentation assidue des femmes
les amitiés ou les amours féminines ont
été une dimension très importante de
beauvoir et peu commenté beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes sont attirées à la
fois par les ors et la fois par les
femmes
mais cette tendance est très fortement
réprimées par la société telle qu'elle
est qu'ils persuadent la femme qu'ils
veulent est persuadé que finalement sa
fonction sexuelle
c'est avant tout une fonction
reproductrice et que ça doit passer
nécessairement par année racisme
hétérosexuels tout y est cette idée
aussi qu' on n'est pas enfermé dans une
identité sexuelle qu'on peut passer de
l'un à l'autre avoir envie de se
découvrir de découvrir son corps tomber
amoureuse d'un être plus que d'argent
romain d'un sexe donc je trouve qu'il ya
une modernité avait quelque chose de
révolutionnaire la dent à l'époque tous
les manuscrits de beauvoir sont refusés
mais pas question de renoncer
sa priorité c'est la littérature pas la
politique
un exemple en 1933 elle rend visite à
sartre à berlin sartre succède à raymond
aron son petit camarade de l'école
normale supérieure comme professeur à
l'institut français en allemagne il
clair vient de prendre le pouvoir
la menace nazie et l'antisémitisme règne
pourtant contrairement à aaron ni
beauvoir ni sartre ne prenne la mesure
du danger
[Musique]
entre 33 et 39 hitler multiplient coup
de force et provocation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon voire comme la grande majorité
des français reste pacifistes et quand
la france signent les accords de munich
un pacte de non-agression avec
l'allemagne elle avoue comme beaucoup un
lâche soulagement
un an plus tard c'est la guerre peu
après sa mobilisation
sartre est fait prisonnier en allemagne
simone professeur à paris depuis trois
ans se retrouve seul elle assiste à la
débâcle de juin 40
[Musique]
le choc est terrible elle prend
conscience pour la première fois que
prises dans les fracas de l'histoire
elle ne maîtrise pas son existence
pour voir n'a aucune sympathie pour le
régime de vichy elle déteste les valeurs
conservatrices qu'il incarne en 1941
quand sartre relâchait revient à paris
ils vont même tenté de réunir quelques
intellectuels opposants mais très vite
cette initiative tourner court
ils ne s'engageront pas davantage ils
sont résistants dans l'esprit mais au
fond sartre et beauvoir sont comportés
comme la plupart des français il était
dans cette complicité objective de tous
les français avec l'occupant allemand
oui ils ont été résistants du point de
vue des idées mais pas de l'action du
tout
[Musique]
dans les faits leurs priorités de vivre
au jour le jour
chaque matin ils se retrouvent au flore
pour écrire car seuls les cafés sont
chauffés dans sa petite chambre d'hôtel
beauvoir improvisent des repas pour les
amis
[Musique]
ces préoccupations principales sait
faire à manger c'est trouver de quoi se
nourrir et nourrir la petite famille
c'est en quelque sorte d'organiser la
vie au quotidien
[Musique]
durant la guerre sartre et beauvoir vont
petit à petit s'intégrer à la vie
artistique et littéraire
[Musique]
ils deviennent amis avec camus le
sculpteur giacometti picasso hemingway
en 1943 gallimard publient l'être et le
néant de sartre et leurs mots de
beauvoir l'invité dans ce texte le
castor s'inspire du trio amoureux vécu
avec olga et sartre elle parle de désir
de jalousie de folie le succès est
immédiat
on évoque même pour le prix goncourt en
1944 le conflit touche à sa fin
[Musique]
pouvoir a changé elle est très loin de
la professeure inconnu et apolitique des
années 30
avec la guerre elle a compris que son
destin est lié à l'histoire et aux
autres
[Musique]
avec sartre elle combien s'engager et
façonner le monde qui vient
[Musique]
à partir de la publication de l'inviter
beauvoir s'impose comme une auteur
majeur
elle multiplie romans et ses théâtres
[Musique]
tous les hommes sont mortels
les bruits inutiles
pour une morale de l'ambiguïté pyrrhus
et cinéaste
elle obtiendra le prix goncourt quelques
années plus tard pour les mandarins
la conférence de sartre
l'existentialisme est un humanisme est
un véritable événement l'anticonformisme
du couple sartre beauvoir fascine il
incarne la mode existentialiste qui
envahit saint germain des prés et ils ne
sont pas les derniers à s'amuser
[Musique]
les socialistes ce que vous en ferez
vous autres
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
ans
dans cette après guerre sartre est bon
voire sont sur tous les fronts il fonde
la revue les temps modernes dont
beauvoir deviendra le pilier le titre
est inspiré d'un film de charlot qu'ils
adorent leur volonté est de peser sur
les choix idéologiques et politiques qui
se dessine pour cela ils réunissent les
plus brillants esprits de l'époque
camille aaron mauriac la notoriété de
beauvoir est telle qu elle est invitée
pour une tournée de conférences aux
états unis
elle découvre pour la première fois à
new york elle est fascinée
il n'ya quelque chose dans l'air qui
rend le sommeil inutiles dit-elle
elle est prise dans un tourbillon de
conférences cocktails soirées
[Musique]
elle observe les femmes qui souvent par
le chiffon entre elles quand les hommes
discutent argent et politique elle qui
s'est toujours sentie l'égal des hommes
trouvent les américaines très
dépendantes de leur mari en marge de ces
conférences
elle devient ami avec le grand écrivain
noir richard wright petit fils d'esclave
avec lui elle découvre la ségrégation
qui règne à harlem
[Musique]
le racisme c'est la doctrine qui pensent
justifier des tables et des
discriminations entre les êtres humains
t'as pas l'air raf est bien le sexisme
c'est l'attitude qui prête à rétablir
discrimination entre les êtres humains
d'après leurs chèques se met en place
dans son esprit effectivement un
parallèle entre eux la ségrégation
raciale et la sécurisation sexiste
sur les conseils d'une amie simone
contacter un écrivain communiste nelson
algren
il écrit sur les déclassés du rêve
américain elle parle le rencontrer chez
lui à chicago il habite dans une
banlieue pauvre dans une sorte de cabane
sans salle de bain immédiatement elle
lui demande d'aller visiter les
bas-fonds de chicago a n'a pas peur elle
aime rentrer dans les bars un peu sombre
et bizarre elle à malley dans les
quartiers où il ya des prostituées les
les dealers el mout des drogues des sept
premières rencontres
le coup de foudre est réciproque bien
plus passionnelle qu'avec sartre
[Musique]
e
c'est la naissance de l'amour fou on
découvre une simone de beauvoir presque
midinettes elle elle montre un autre
aspect de sa féminité et peut-être de
ses désirs qui n'étaient pas satisfaits
a paris il ya quelque chose de
d'émouvant et de primaire voilà avant
son départ
algret lui offre une bague en laiton
symbole de leur union
elle apportera toute sa vie jusque dans
son cercueil
dans l'avion qui la ramène à paris
simone fond en larmes
et dès son arrivée elle lui écrit ma
vraie chaude place et contre votre coeur
aimant mais les lettres sont enflammés
elle dit j'ai envie de vous je ne pense
qu à vous j'ai envie de vous toucher
votre odeur me manque
l'histoire d'amour entre beauvois real
grain durera plusieurs années en toute
transparence avec sartre bien sûr
beauvoir retournera à chicago algues
reviendra à paris il s'écriront des
lettres brûlante
[Musique]
on a beaucoup glosé sur le fait que dans
sa correspondance avec nelson
elle lui dit j'aimerais ta petite femme
d'intérieur et et je suis toute petite
grenouille d'amour et je fais un truc un
peu minaudant on dit ah vous voyez la
grande féministe etc
il voudrait être auprès de lui pour lui
faire la cuisine pour les blanchir son
linge qu'elle peut plus passer de lui
que c'est un manque terrible qu'elle
pleure et sauf qu'au final il lui dit on
se marie tu viens vivre avec moi elle
dit non pas du tout je vais rester à
paris avec sartre
algret ne signera pas rompre
définitivement quelques années plus tard
en lisant la force des choses
dans ce texte autobiographique elle
relativise leur histoire d'amour au
profit de son lien privilégié avec
sartre
[Musique]
à son retour des états unis
beauvoir reprend un projet qui l'habite
depuis toujours écrire sur sa vie mais
pour cela il faut tout d'abord
comprendre ce qu'est une femme lui dit
sartre ainsi naît le projet du deuxième
sexe
pendant deux ans elle ingurgite tout ce
qu'elles trouvent sur le sujet
histoire biologie psychanalyse
anthropologie littérature elle a cette
idée phénoménal extraordinaire est au
fond très très libératrice le dire je
vais faire un livre qui sera un livre
encyclopédique où je vais essayer
d'aller trouver pourquoi on dit que on
est inférieur aux autres
tout d'abord beauvoir déconstruit la
notion d'idéal féminin
la femme ne n'est pas fragile dévoué à
l'homme protecteur depuis l'origine de
l'humanité
le mâle cherche à la dominer et à
prendre le pouvoir
[Musique]
il ya eu un mort dans la nuit les temps
où la force physique ça compte
énormément les plus forts se sont
approprié les droits le pouvoir de
manière à avoir également d'après mines
ans économique grossièrement pour être
ce qui est trés toujours sûr de manger
ce qu'on appelle l'universel féminin est
en fait le fruit d'une longue histoire
du moyen âge à aujourd'hui un imaginaire
façonné dès la petite enfance
[Musique]
pour voir révèle les stratégies
masculine elle met en évidence que
depuis toujours les hommes occupent la
place centrale
les hommes partent au combat alors que
les femmes restent à quai
[Musique]
pourtant elles aussi sont dans l'action
mais souvent laissées dans l'ombre
certes le sujet c'est l'homme et puis à
côté il ya cet objet voilà qu'on appelle
la femme et elle va se demander ça veut
dire quoi du coup pour nous les femmes
de grandir en étant l'autre en n'étant
jamais le sujet on est toujours l'objet
l'homme voit la femme avant tout comme
un objet avant de juger son intelligence
son humour son charme
il va se demander si elle est belle sexy
[Musique]
dans la pub à la télé dans les magazines
les femmes trophées sont légion
mais loin de s'en tenir à des analyses
abstraite beauvoir intègre à son travail
les aspects les plus concrets de la vie
des femmes
elle revient de façon clinique sur ce
que l'on sait de la physiologie du corps
féminin le fonctionnement du vagin du
clitoris des règles
[Musique]
elle se penche aussi sur les enjeux du
travail des femmes s'appuyant sur des
témoignages des cous de femmes divorcées
pour beauvoir le point central et
l'autonomie financière
[Musique]
mais enfin je penserai que la femme que
le coup de chance de cinq jeunes à la
vie c'est celle qui travaille seul qui
gagne sa vie
je pense que l'émancipation de la femme
commence par son émancipation économique
saddam la dépendance qui vous permet
même si le travail est un dieu de ne pas
vous plier aux désirs volonté d'un homme
autre tabou la maternité dans
l'imaginaire collectif
l'instinct maternel est présenté comme
l'essence de la féminité beauvoir montre
que la réalité est loin de ce fantasme
[Musique]
ce qui ressortait de ça c'était que la
maternité n'était pas obligatoire la
maternité n'était pas une fin en soi
de nombreuses femmes veulent avorter ce
qui est interdit
quelques années avant la publication du
deuxième sexe sous le régime de vichy qu
une femme a été guillotiné pour avoir
procédé à des ivg clandestins
[Musique]
vous
la vérité lui donner raison elle a
montré que la maternité pouvait être
pour beaucoup de femmes un piège dans
son livre pour voir à bordeaux si
longuement le poids des tâches ménagères
cuisine lessive aspirateur contrairement
aux images kids hynix vendus par la
publicité
elle montre que tenir une maison est un
labeur aliénant sans fin
[Musique]
et la ménagère elle va faire à manger
pour les autres fr bon plein bon plat
puis en cinq minutes après six heures de
travail tout est dévoré tout est à
refaire
[Musique]
qui fait à manger qui change les couches
c'est le grand sujet parce que elle a
redonné une place à ces questions qui a
été méprisée avec beaucoup de
condescendance par les hommes mais que
peut bien faire ma femme pour tuer le
temps pendant que moi je travaille
voyons voyons d'un mois en vue d'un
moyen le ménage bien sûr bien sûr course
et ouais je crois qu'il déplaît et la
condition imposée à la femme c'est le
travail qu'on exporte un travail non
salariés travail non payé une plus juste
répartition des tâches ménagères est un
enjeu particulièrement fort pour une
femme qui travaille et ce que disait
beauvoir résonne encore de nos jours
70% des tâches ménagères pèse sur les
épaules des femmes
nous savons bien aujourd'hui que la
vraie raison de l'inégalité des sexes
c'est encore le fait que la femme oui
accès au monde extérieur où on
professionnels à toutes les fonctions
possibles mais c'était encore elle qui
faisait le reste
ça veut dire la double journée de
travail l'imaginaire des années 50 peut
faire sourire et pourtant en sommes-nous
si loin quand on voit la façon dont nos
vie parfaite sont exposées sur les
réseaux sociaux
la mise en scène de soi par des femmes
et de leur maison sur instagram
ça relève de sa de ce mythe de la
ménagère des années 50 on est dans les
années 50 et donc de la bonne maîtresse
de maison qui fait des bons petits plats
ou chez elle tout est impeccable et
beauvoir serait folle si elle voyait
qu'on en est encore là
en 1949 la sortie du deuxième sexe fait
polémique
on traite son auteur de vieille fille
frigide pas mariée sans enfant beauvoir
détonne beaucoup la présente comme
l'ombre de sartre on parle d'elle comme
notre dame de sartre ou la grande
chartreuse
ça m'a agacé de temps en temps bien
entendu qu'en janvier dans un critique
que je n'aurais jamais rien écrit s'il
est par contre ça ou que c'était sartre
qui avait fait ma carrière littéraire ou
que c'était même quelques-uns l'ont dit
que c'est sa fille écrit mes livres elle
reçoit des déluges d' insulte c'est des
menaces de mort des menaces de viol on
l'a attaquée elle comme une dangereuse
révolutionnaire et et comme une
humiliation du mag
au revoir et traîné dans la boue par la
droite françois mauriac éditorialistes
vedettes au figaro s'indigne dorénavant
nous savons tous du vagin de la patronne
des temps modernes
[Musique]
et
c'est la rumeur du vagin quoi c'est la
peur la peur du sexe féminin la peur de
la puissance du sexe féminin et le vagin
le corps féminin reste un continent
oublié et pas seulement oublié mais
répugnant déboutant on n'a pas envie
d'aller voir on n'a pas envie de de
savoir la gauche aussi s'offusque les
communistes explique que ces bases
description graveleuses cette ordure qui
soulèvent le coeur n'a aucun intérêt
pour les ouvrières qu'elle se fasse
attaquer par l'extrême gauche ça
m'étonne pas du tout c'est ce que
vivront après tout les féministes les
années 70 à savoir que les féministes
seront toujours accusé le sont toujours
à l'heure actuelle de diviser la classe
ouvrière ou en gros on leur dit bah
faisons la révolution et puis à ce
moment là tous les problèmes soient
réglés parce que il ya eu des quantités
d'hommes qui ont été absolument révulsés
et même des hommes que je pensais être
de gauche que ce prophète relie beyrouth
france être égalitaire et qui ont été
révoltés par ce livre parce que je
ridiculisait le mal français mali par
exemple camille malgré les critiques le
deuxième sexe est un succès de librairie
trente mille exemplaires sont vendus dès
la première semaine les femmes l'achète
mais pas seulement un tiers des lettres
reçues viennent des hommes le deuxième
sexe au sein des forums parce que c'est
un bouleversement devenir le deuxième
sexe et pour un homme durant des
décennies beauvoir va être invité
partout en europe mais aussi au brésil
au japon
accueilli comme une rock-star le livre
s'impose au fil du temps comme un
best-seller mondial
[Musique]
et
un livre iconique qui sera traduit en
121 une langue et se vendra à des
millions d'exemplaires jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
divise le monde bloc contre bloc
d'un côté le modèle américain celui de
la libre entreprise de la société de
consommation
ce que vaut voir très critiques
appellent le système de l'homme de
l'organisation
l'amérique des années 50 c'est aussi la
parano obsédé par la menace communiste
une chasse aux sorcières le mccarthysme
se met en place
on s'écoute on sait plus où se
soupçonnent on dénonce les personnalités
qui s'engagent à gauche
de l'autre côté le bloc de l'est est
sous la coupe réglée des communistes
fort du prestige de l'armée rouge l'urss
impose son modèle
la révolution promet une société sans
classe par haine de la société
bourgeoise ce couple engagé choisi son
camp celui de la révolution et du
prolétariat sartre monte en première
ligne
il écrit tout anti communiste est un
chien l'amérique a la rage
beauvoir le défendra toujours sans
nuance
[Musique]
ce compagnonnage avec les communistes ne
va pas sans tensions bien sûr sartre et
beauvoir dénoncent certains des crimes
staliniens
ils vivent mal l'écrasement de budapest
par les chars russes en 1956 et la
répression du printemps de prague par
moscou en 68
mais in fine est fasciné par la violence
révolutionnaire ils le remettent pas en
cause l'idéal communiste
ferme les yeux sur les crimes de masse
symbole mondial de la conscience de
gauche ils sont invités plusieurs fois à
moscou
fidel castro leur déroule le tapis rouge
l'argument de beauvoir et sartre se
manifeste aussi bien à cuba que en urss
cancan scheer
un règlement en parle parce qu'il
assiste quand même dans ses voyages
officiels
évidemment il assiste à une mise en
scène comme voie de l'édification du
socialisme c'est un figeant il est pour
des gens aussi intelligents qui qui ne
voit que ce qu'ils voulaient voir
évoluer et croire tout ce qu'ils
voulaient croire en 1955
ils sont invités en chine comme beaucoup
d'intellectuels français
il fantasme la révolution maoïste à son
retour
beaurevoir publié un texte enthousiaste
la longue marche
[Musique]
effectivement yann thesse de discours de
béatitude comme s'il part à 10 sur la
terre avait été enfin incarner réaliser
et là il une partie de leur cerveau
dormir
bien des années plus tard beau voir
revenir à ce livre et reconnaîtra sa
naïveté sur les pays de l'est mais
contrairement à camus aaron jamais elle
ne renoncera à l'idéal révolutionnaire
ea sa violence
elle pense la politique de façon binaire
proposant le camp du bien et du mal tout
comme la jeune fille y croyait à l'enfer
est au paradis mais l'anti impérialisme
de beauvoir c'est aussi un engagement
sans faille pour la décolonisation
dès 1945 elle suit de près les
mouvements de libération des pays
colonisés pour elle ces peuples sont un
autre visage du prolétariat
[Musique]
dès le début de la guerre d'algérie
beauvoir en partie pour l'indépendance
[Musique]
les temps modernes dénonce la torture
pratiquée par l'armée française
[Musique]
nous avons des raisons d'être contre la
guerre d'indochine mêmes raisons d'être
contre la guerre d'algérie et pas
seulement contre les tortures et contre
la guerre sachent la guerre appliquer
les tortures elle s'expose est insulté
menacé par des partisans de l'algérie
française
des attentats visent l'appartement de
sartre et les locaux des temps modernes
et
pouvoir se battra jusqu'au bout sans
ménagement pour tous les combats de la
décolonisation
[Musique]
au début des années 70 les mouvements
féministes fleurissent partout dans le
monde
l'époque est à l'émancipation des corps
à la jouissance la revendication de la
liberté sexuelle
j'ai toujours été pauvres pour tout le
monde à tous les âges et pour tous les
sexes en france le mlf mouvement de
libération des femmes organise débats et
manifestations
pour cette génération beauvoir est une
pionnière
le deuxième sexe une référence et dans
ses textes autobiographiques la force de
l'âge
la force des choses pour voir prouve que
l'on peut prendre en main son existence
briser les carcans
[Musique]
avec de la volonté avec l'énergie on
peut rompre avec ce déterminisme c'était
et d'ailleurs je vais vous le montrez le
mois que simone de beauvoir
je ne veux pas me marier je ne veux pas
d'enfant
ce qui est un scandale à l'état pur à
l'époque je veux être libre et je veux
vivre ma vie comme je le veux personne
n'avait dit ça comme ça pour voir
inspire et beauvoir s'engage en 1971
elle signe dans le nouvel observateur le
manifeste des 343 [__] qui descend
l'avortement illégal à l'époque
son nom apparaît aux côtés de ceux de
jeanne moreau catherine deneuve agnès
varda ya eu et font douter
manifestations dans les rues sur les
boulevards de bras pour réclamer la
liberté de l'avortement qui intéresse
aussi bielle ouvrière que la bourgeoise
ce problème là elle fonde aussi avec
l'avocate gisèle halimi choisir la cause
des femmes elles descendent ensemble une
jeune fille de 16 ans condamné pour
avoir avorté clandestinement après un
viol
pour voir sans jamais chercher à se
faisait comme modèle écoute est toutes
les femmes qui viennent vers elle elle a
eu le génie de donner le dirait le
départ d'un mouvement de conquête
c'est à dire qu'elle est la donnée aux
autres femmes
le l'envi de conquérir le monde
l' envie de conquérir l'égalité et la
liberté
[Musique]
beauvoir a passé sa vie à courir le
monde pour défendre ses idéaux
avec sa pelure sans jamais baisser les
bras
mais depuis toujours elle sait que l'on
ne sort pas vainqueur face aux années
qui passent à 30 ans 40 ans elle ne
cesse de se trouver vieille parle de la
vérole du temps qui dévore son visage
c'est pas simplement la dégradation du
corps c'est aussi le fait que nous
sommes promis à la mort et que cette
disparition qui est une sorte de
scandale elle le vit très profondément à
chacun des moments de son existence
je crois que c'est parce que j'ai le
goût du bonheur d'une manière très forte
que j'ai également le sens du malheur
est que le malheur apparaît comme
quelque chose de tragique en 1964 elle
publie un de ses plus beaux textes
une mort très douce elle y raconte
frontalement l'agonie de sa mère rongée
par un cancer et parle sans pudeur de ce
cadavre en sursis il ya une une sorte de
tendresse et en même temps de frayeur
parce qu'elle y voit sa propre mort
évidemment en reflets devant le corps
dégradé et qu'il abandonne de sa mère et
on découvre encore un autre aspect de
simone de beauvoir qui est une sorte
quand même de de chaleur de douceur
d'attention qu'elle a pour sa mère entre
à nourrir
elle écrira plus tard un essai la
vieillesse qui dénoncent l'abandon des
personnes âgées
ce naufrage de la vieillesse
elle va le vivre aussi aux côtés d'un
sartre presque aveugle ravagé les
dernières années de sa vie
[Musique]
bâle a révolutionné la définition de
l'amour l'amour ça n'est pas cette
espèce de fusion monogame où la femme
attend son mari à la maison avec le
gâteau où personne ne se tromper on fait
tous semblant de s'aimer à la folie et
que rien d'autre n'existe que ça non ces
deux consciences libres qui s'aiment qui
se frotte à la vie qui se frotte aux
autres qui se frotte aux infidélités
mais qui réfléchit ensemble qui avancent
ensemble qui s'apprend des choses
ensemble et pis surtout qui a respecté
les thuel réciproque entre les deux les
deux individus dans leur relation ce qui
me touche le plus c'est l'égalité et jeu
et je crois qu'elle le dit plusieurs
fois c'est la relation finalement la
plus égalitaire qu'elle ait connu côte à
côte ils ont écrit leurs oeuvres peser
sur le siècle
pas un jour sans se parler se lire
s'écouter
[Musique]
lorsque sartre hummer en avril 1981 le
choc est si brutale qu'elle n'imagine
pas lui survivre
[Musique]
elle écrira sa mort nous sépare
ma mort ne nous réunira pas c'est ainsi
il est déjà beau que nos vies et puis si
longtemps s'accorder
[Musique]
pour voir moeurs six ans plus tard jour
pour jour après son compagnon le 14
avril 1986
[Musique]
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
suivent son cercueil jusqu'au cimetière
du montparnasse des anonymes des femmes
venues du monde entier
[Musique]
des femmes qui depuis deux générations
en générations puissent chez beauvoir la
force de continuer le combat
oui
[Musique]